[Musique]
aujourd'hui on va tester un nouveau
smartphone qui est sorti ya à peine un
mois
c'est le sony xperia x1 ultra le grand
modèle est aussi le sony xperia x1 qui
est sorti cette année qui succède au
sony xperia x1 qui est sorti en 2016 ce
x1 ultra a l'air d'être très bien à
beaucoup davantage à commencer par la
taille de son écran mais ça on va le
regarder tout de suite ensemble
ce sony xperia x1 ultra il est présenté
dans cette boîte une boîte qui est très
sobre qui est très sympa on peut la
regarder un peu tous les côtés on a les
spécifications techniques un appareil
photo 23 mégapixels qu'on va pouvoir
retrouver à l'arrière un 5 mégapixels à
l'avant on parle à tous après un écran 6
pouces full hd directement borderless de
lui adresser une batterie deux mille
sept cent millions perreur ça c'est le
processeur le médiathèque et llopez 20
et celui ci contient 32 gigabits de
batterie on a du wifi du bluetooth le
bluetooth et du 4 points 2 on peut
rajouter une micro sd
on fonctionne sous android cette nous
gave voilà un petit peu voilà ce qu'il
en est un petit peu de cette boîte qui
est qui est ma foi très très esthétique
et ont comme on peut le voir
7ce pareil peut comporter double carte
sim ce qui est très bien pour les usages
professionnels alors on va l'ouvrir et
regarder comment c'est fait à
l'intérieur donc vous avez ici votre
appareil on me voit au travers beaux
jours vous avez ici votre appareil dans
la boîte une bonne qui est quand même
très très sympathique
on peut le dire hop là ça c'est ce qu'on
appelle [ __ ] un téléphone en l'air
voilà une botte qui est très sympa ça on
peut le reconnaître votre sony est ici
voler c'est un très très grand écran on
va l'allumer ensemble on va regarder ce
qu'on voit déjà hop on regardera le
téléphone après on va d'abord checker
l'intérieur la boîte dans l'intérieur de
la boîte vous
et ensuite un petit guide de départ
votre adaptateur secteur pour brancher
le câble pour venir charger le téléphone
il ya les écouteurs qui normalement sont
présents mais qui moi dans mon modèle de
démo ne sont pas présents voilà un petit
peu et hop tout ce qu'on peut dire sur
cette jolie boîte
passons maintenant à l'appareil en lui
même ça c'est le modèle noir il existe
dans quelle couleur or blanc noir et
rose noir c'est très sobre c'est très
joli
je trouve que c'est un modèle qui est
plutôt bien réussi qui est quand même
dans des dimensions qui reste vraiment
vraiment correct il fait 16,5 cm au
niveau de la hauteur 7 9 cm de long et
une épaisseur de 0,8 cm on voit
effectivement l'objectif sur la face
avant
un flash qui est ici qui va vous
permettre effectivement mais d'avoir je
dirais ddc lfi qui seront probablement
un peu plus stabilisée on va tester ces
ensembles tout à l'heure le port usb
c'est qu'ils se situe ici un haut
parleur son côté le port jack sur le
dessus sur le côté nous avons là le port
pour la carte la carte la double carte
sim et les cartes sd pas si on voit bien
le numéro un et la numéro 2 sur la
gauche son arc sim et sans la droite
micro sd qu'on peut incorporer
directement là de l'autre côté on a
effectivement ici le bouton pour
l'allumer un autre bouton pour
l'appareil photo qui est situé juste en
dessous et puis elle des boutons ici
aussi sur le côté
voilà pour faire le tour un peu de cet
appareil puis on va très bien l'arrière
aussi cet appareil photo 23 mégapixels
avec le flash ici voilà un appareil qui
est somme toute assez esthétique je
n'allume donc là c'est un petit peu long
démarrage android comme je vous disais
cela android 7.0 nougat qui est sur cet
appareil qui démarra bienvenue français
premiers pas à leurs premiers pas moi ça
m'intéresse
j'ai pris connaissance des informations
importantes garde sécurité j'ai compris
que les prétentions de nice à
saint-etienne et gna gna gna gna gna gna
accepté bienvenue inséré
karassine donc là il ya tous les
paramétrages effectivement de sécurité
des services google l'appareil est prêt
donc là effectivement toutes les options
pour pouvoir
je dirais switcher d'un vieil appareil
au nouveau et puis faire la connaissance
avec avec son appareil
voilà pour la mise en route de cet
appareil on est sur un écran bord à bord
on a tout eu effectivement la sensation
d'immersion d'être directement dans le
téléphone
c'est quand même très très agréable à
regarder alors j'espère juste que c'est
un appareil qui sera résistant en termes
de en terme de choc
je pense que oui ça serait quand même
dommage je vais pas m'amuser à le jeter
pour tester en tout cas voilà c'est un
appareil qui vraiment super esthétique
la prise en main est simple tu vois
effectivement moi j'ai pas des mains de
bûcheron mais on tient très très bien
dans sa main en terme de sensations de
prise en main ça me paraît vraiment
convenable on va tout de suite ce qu'il
en est on a accès directement aux
informations importantes pour moi c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment top alors on va
regarder un petit peu ce que cet
appareil a dans le ventre
comme je lisais déjà c'est un écran 6
pouces bord à bord ça fait effectivement
une belle diagonale un bord en aluminium
je sais pas si on le voit bien mais
effectivement c'est de l'aluminium il ya
un côté assez assez assez premium dans
ce produit au niveau du toucher ça fait
vraiment qualitatif
l'appareil photo à l'avant c'est un 16
mégapixels on voit qu'il a effectivement
un flash sur le côté et un stabilisateur
optique dessus si vous tremble un petit
peu si ça bouge
le stabilisateur optique de vous
corriger cela il va vous permet d'avoir
des photos qui pourraient être vraiment
clair vraiment stable et ça c'est
vraiment plutôt bien il ya un capteur
exmor r s et qui doit faire des bonnes
photos à faible éclairage
on va les tester ça on va tester
l'appareil dans quelques instants pour
effectivement pouvoir se regroupent un
appareil photo très très pratique pour
vous éclairer pour faire des scènes
fille qu'il n'y a pas beaucoup de
lumière ça évite de devoir utiliser la
lumière de l'écran qui va vous envoyer
en espèces de 2 flash un peu aveugle ans
dans la tête et qui normalement
fonctionne bien à faible luminosité et
surtout un appareil photo avec un
grand-angle donc on fait des selles
fille avec beaucoup d'amis c'est
extrêmement pratique
l'appareil photo à l'arrière c'est un 23
mégapixels avec un autofocus hybride
pareil on a un capteur exmor r s à
l'arrière et on va pouvoir faire des
photos en faible luminosité on peut
monter jusqu en iso 6400 donc
effectivement qu'il n'y a pas de lumière
nuit ou les soirées un petit peu sombre
on doit pouvoir quant à elle faire des
photos côté processeur on est sur un
processeur médiathèque et llopez 20 64
bits avec 6 gigaoctets de ram dans
l'appareil tout en sachant que si vous
optez pour le sony xperia à 1 et pas
l'ultra le 1 vous aurez 3 giga de
mémoire il ya un petit logiciel
intelligent à l'intérieur qui s'appelle
le smart cleaner qui va désactiver les
applications que vous n'utilisez pas et
qui va nettoyer le cash ce qui est quand
même relativement pratique surtout quand
on sait qu'on a toujours besoin de
mémoire pour ses photos et pour ses
vidéos pour sa musique enfin pour toutes
ces applications côté stockage il est
disponible en 32 gigas mais aussi en
liga on peut monter jusqu'à 256 giga
lorsque vous allez rajoute effectivement
une carte microsd ici sur le côté il
pèse 180 8 grammes c'est vrai qu'il n'a
pas l'air particulièrement lourd je
trouverais un peu plus l'ouvrir comme
l'iphone 6 ans qui passe même dans ma
poche pour voir qu'il est très grand ce
n'est pas négligeable
il tourne dos rigides sous android 7.0
louga la batterie cdu 2700 milliampères
heures et le bluetooth cdu 4.2 pas de
bluetooth 5 dessus par contre
effectivement c'est intéressant ça qui à
de l'usb type c et on va très bien que
l'usb ticks et s'impose comme étant un
standard alors c'est un produit qui est
sorti il ya pas longtemps mené et qu'on
peut trouver au tarif de 399 euros sur
le modèle 32 gigas donc là on va essayer
de faire les photos à faible luminosité
donc je vois ici j'ai les paramètres
effectivement de la luminosité couleur
et luminosité
je peux monter un peu ma luminosité pour
m'éclairer je suis quand je le monte à
fond je suis complètement surexposé
c'est beaucoup trop beaucoup trop blanc
on va se faire à la une expo un peu plus
correct ici on peut rajouter de la
couleur je peux soit effectivement le
devenir pour réchauffer la photo soit
venir sur la gauche la salle berthe
revient pas c'est pas terrible
légèrement venir sarko mais dès mon
visage photo
voilà une photo fantastique et la photo
est très clair ça c'est vrai que c'est
assez incroyable
ça marche très très bien faible
luminosité du coup si on fait un peu
plus dans cet appareil photo nasa
résolution le retardateur couleurs
luminosité suivi d'objets capture
automatique touché pour régler mise au
point une luminosité
autre truc qui est plutôt bien pensée
dans cet appareil c'est quand on est à
distance comme ça et qu'on veut faire
une photo pas besoin d'aller chercher
appuyer sur le bouton c'est fastidieux
ses champs il suffit de se mettre à
distance et de mettre sa main salah
reconnaît on ouvre sa main devant ça
reconnaît la paume de la main et ça fait
la photo et ça marche super
donc là je suis en extérieur en train de
filmer avec la caméra de l'avant sans
micro un slot micro sans rien je suis
directement sur le téléphone
donc c'est plutôt pas mal ça reconnaît
directement ma tronche
est ce que je peux faire des points pas
sûr mais en tout cas c'est pas mal voilà
tu vois il ya le linge qui sèche
derrière on montre tout ici le linge
sèche
heureusement il n'y a pas de culotte
normalement c'est pas mal ça fan auto
focus alors le sont je pense que le son
est pas terrible en restent calmes sur
le sens d'un appareil photo même si
effectivement l'image a l'air d'être
d'une super qualité à faire le point à
faire la netteté à faire le focus
directement quand on vient quand on part
je pense que le son est pas terrible
on va essayer de ploguer un petit micro
robe dessus pour voir la différence et
voir si ça change quelque chose
normalement ça doit changer l'histoire
donc là j'ai un petit micro qu'essuie
normalement ça devrait changer le son le
son de riz de mieux ça permet de
comparer un de se rendre compte
effectivement si le son d'origine avec
le micro d'origine même si c'est pas
fait pour et bien où est pas bien qu'à
côté vidéo ça a l'air d'être quand même
plutôt pas mal
la up on va essayer de bouger un peu
voir s'il ya une stabilisation qui se
fait ou pas on la vend à faire
exactement le même exercice
là j'ai mon appareil à la main
maintenant on va tester directement avec
le petit micro road pour voir la
différence du son pouvoir comparer hop
je le mets là alors le seul inconvénient
et ça c'est un peu con c'est que la
prise jack
elle est posée à l'avant au même endroit
que l'appareil photo ce qui fait que là
on voit l'avant du micro et j'ai pas mis
la même route si je mets la moumoute
dessus il ya plus d'image et ça c'est
quand même relativement dommage mais
sinon bon c'est pas mal sinon on doit le
dire la qualité la qualité et bien je
sais pas si ça fait et pas d'autofocus
dessus sur l'avant et des trains que sur
l'arrière mais en tout cas c'est vrai
que la qualité de l'image en tout cas
est plutôt pas dégueu donc bon pour
l'instant un bon point donc là on tourne
dans un endroit qui est extrêmement
sombre
je t'ai pas de bruit parce que ça ne le
couloir c'est une zone de passage
y'a pas quasiment pas de lumière il ya
un peu de lumière naturelle par la
barrière d'un peu par là mais c'est très
sombre et au final le rendu quand on
regarde et quand même pas mal du tout je
trouve que en termes de qualité vidéo
l'emmener sur la caméra devant c'est pas
mal on va mettre en tester sur la caméra
derrière maintenant rendus sur la
canebière que ça bouge un petit peu
parce que je le tiens directement la
magistrate stabilisateur mais c'est vrai
que l'image à lire quand même plutôt pas
mal et c'est encore faible luminosité
l'appareil est bien là sur les vidéos
entre 15 pour l'instant c'est assez
couramment donc là si on compare faible
luminosité on a des goûts des mondes
iphone 6 s et de côté le nouveau sonia
xperia x1 ultra et franchement il pas
photo c'est le cas de le dire on va très
bien du côté de l'iphone 6 aces c'est
beaucoup plus sombre tout de suite
derrière le fond et son bord ce n'est
vraiment pas de lumière c'est vraiment
très très sont donc donc c'est normal
par contre de l'autre côté
le sony offre une luminosité qui est
dingue même par faible
l'idée c'est assez impressionnant après
quand j'ai vu ma lumière il ya aussi une
différence
on va regarder des gens au niveau de la
mise au point le qu'elle fait le mieux
le point lequel fait le point par point
comment ça marche
si je me recule si je m'avance un peu
plus près voir un petit peu la
différence sur les sur les deux
téléphones normalement il ya quand même
une différence est là on est en
extérieur et en combat la mise au point
comment ça fonctionne d'un côté sur le
sony xperia et de l'autre côté sur
l'iphone 6 s il reste donc une
profondeur d'image ont plus ce qui est
vraiment sympa on n'a pas le même effet
et quand même une différence au niveau
de l'optique et au niveau du rendu de la
qualité
lâchez tient tous les deux à la main le
système d'un côté et de l'autre côté
l'expérience c'est un ultra et
franchement là il n'y a aucune lumière
dans les pièces
il n'y a pas photo pour moi le sony
xperia x1 ultra est vraiment meilleure
un appareil photo de vraiment meilleure
qualité et le rendu est vraiment mieux
que l'iphone 6 bon verdict un petit peu
de ce téléphone pour en avoir fait le
tour
je trouve que c'est un bon produit alors
c'est peut-être pas la bête de course
n'est peut-être pas l'appareil qui va
permettre de brancher et d'avoir bien
réalité virtuelle avec un casque comme
tu peux l'avoir sur le samsung galaxy s
suite mais il faut comparer ce qui est
comparable on est sur un produit qui
coûte moins de 400 euros
9 avec 32 gigas de mémoire pour moi
c'est un bon produit la qualité photo
est là la qualité vidéo et là on est sur
un android os 7.0 nous bien ça
fonctionne c'est fermer mon avis ce
téléphone là d'avoir un bon smartphone
de bonne qualité avec une belle capacité
de stockage surtout avec la possibilité
les temps jusqu'à 256 gigas qui est
quand même pas mal si pour vous le
téléphone c'est pour avoir des applis
des jeux pour se faire plaisir et que
vous voulez surtout privilégié de faire
belles photos de belles vidéos et de
bons souvenirs ça clairement pour moi
c'est bien c'est très bien et pour moins
de 400 euros
parce que vous allez avoir toutes vos
photos toutes vos vidéos le mode self y
est sympa les photos seront sympas il ya
de quoi se marrer la petite originalité
avec la reconnaissance de la main pour
faire des selphy à distance je trouve ça
vraiment super sympa et voilà il ya
plein de petites choses qui font que au
final c'est peut-être pas the telephone
de 2017
la bête de course tant attendue un
hypothétique iphone 8 ou alors un galaxy
et suite mais pour moi ça c'est vraiment
très très bien
c'est vraiment un très bon téléphone je
trouve que sony a fait du bon boulot là
dessus donc voila un petit peu moi ce
que je peux dire aujourd'hui par rapport
à ce sony xperia x10 un ultra le grand
modèle avec l'écran 6 pouces dites moi
ce que vous en pensez mais témoin tout
en commentaire on en parle je sais pas
si vous en avez si vous connaissiez le
modèle antérieur à le hic ça ou si vous
avez le x à 1 c'est-à-dire avec l'écran
un petit peu politique donc on parle de
100 commentaires merci d'abord regarder
la vie
aussi elle vous a plu si elle vous
intéresser si elle vous a apporté des
informations merci de laisser un pouce
ne pas hésiter à s'abonner pour avoir
toujours plus d'infos sur la high-tech
quant à nous on se retrouve très bientôt
et j'aurai une belle surprise très
prochainement
j'en dis pas plus ciao
[Musique]